so you have to have good habits if you
want to do achieve anything don't worry
about the long-term goal have habits and
atomic habits talks about a trigger
and then a craving
and then the response
and then the satisfaction so me this is
where I learn languages this is where I
wash dishes I have my nice gloves to
keep my hands from getting dishpan hands
and I have no craving to do the dishes
and it's not that attractive but I learn
languages while doing the dishes so that
makes it more attractive and so my
response to that urge the dishes have to
be done or or you know my wife cooks a
lovely meal I've got to clean up so
there's a a need there uh the response
is that I do it while listening to my
language and then there's a satisfaction
that knowing that I've done my share
uh and uh everything is good